Hello, I'm Daven Hiskey, you're watching the
TodayIFoundOut YouTube channel.
In the video today, we're looking at the origin
of the That's what she said and the equivalent
British phrase.
"That's what she said" is thought to have
been around since the 1970s with the earliest
known documented case of it showing up on
Saturday Night Live, spoken by Chevy Chase
in a weekend update skit in 1975, which also
happened to be the first season of SNL.
"That's what she said" was later hugely popularized
thanks to Wayne's World skits on Saturday
Night Live and later usage in the movie "Wayne's
World".
Accross the pond from Saturday Night Live's
studios, a much older equivalent double entendre
inspired phrase had been around for nearly
a century- "said the actress to the bishop".
This phrase is thought to have its origins
as far back as the Edwardian period (around
1901-1910), though it didn't appear in print
until "The Saint" novel "Meet the Tiger" was
published in 1928.
"Said the actress to the bishop" is thought
to derive from the fact that, during early
English theater, actresses very commonly used
prostitution to supplement their stage income.
In fact, their performances on stage often
worked very effectively as a form of advertisement
to men in the audience, who could generally
request an "audience" with a given actress
via so-called "orange-girls"- scantily clad
young teen girls who sold fruit to audience
members.
Because of the so-called "loose morals" of
the actresses, clergymen spent a lot of time
with them...
...trying to get them to turn from their sinful
ways.
Thus, it was a common occurrence for actresses
to confess their sexual sins to the bishops.
Somewhere along the line (and nobody knows
exactly where or when), it became common to
say "as the actress said to the bishop" or
alternatively "said the actress to the bishop"
when someone uttered a phrase that could be
taken sexually, if viewed in the correct light.
"Said the actress to the Bishop" became a
near extinct phrase by the 1970s, but saw
a huge resurgence in common usage relatively
recently due to Ricky Gervais, playing the
character David Brent in the British The Office,
frequently using this wellerism.
In homage to Gervais, Steve Carrel adopted
the American equivalent of "that's what she
said" for his corresponding American The Office
character.
So thanks for watching this video, if you
liked it, please click that like button below
and consider sharing it with anyone you think
might be interested.
And of course if you’re new to TodayIFoundOut,
don’t forget to click the subscribe button
to get more interesting videos like this.
We release a new video almost every single
day, so you’re sure to find something you
find interesting.
Thanks for watching.